now I wasn't going to ask you about
Hillary Clinton because everybody does
but the announcement was today that
she's going to announce on Sunday so you
know are you ready and what are you
gonna wear I don't have to think about
that about what to wear
that was a question no one's asked me
that's right okay well let me ask a
further question somebody from her camp
was on record today saying that they're
going to raise in his words an insane
amount of money and I've said and I
think you probably agree that citizens
united was a terrible ruling that
allowed pretty much unlimited money into
politics we seem to have we seem to have
policy now that is driven by citizens
united in that candidates just want the
money from one guy Sheldon Adelson of
about a hundred million dollars I think
this is what is driving the anti Iran
rhetoric the incredibly prom in we're
both pro-israel but not like the
Republicans that means just great that's
all because they want Sheldon Adelson's
money same thing with the environment
they want the Koch brothers money yep
somehow as bad as we thought citizens
united was it's actually even worse yeah
no I think you're exactly right about
that you know Sheldon Adelson is out
there he gets to pick the candidates and
then he gets to put his money behind
them and see if he can't get those
offices the senators the White House
right this is just crazy madness yeah
you know it's madness and it's scary um
yeah I mean look when I gave the Obama
PAC a million dollars in 2012 I did it
because you know I wanted to show that
we got to get in the game it's on a
million dollar level now and
unfortunately since then every
Democratic candidate in the world is
always hitting me up for money you know
and I tell them you know I you know
that's the book Bachman BuzzFeed today
there's a headline that says Hillary has
my vote but not the million dollars you
know
however there is one candidate who if
they got the nomination
he said if they got the nomination I'm
not made out of money and I might have
to take a job as an over driver but if
you choose to run and you are the
candidate I will find a way to give you
so does does that change your thinking
at all I'm not running for president
but but I do want to say this when we
talk about money I get it about money
and I got it about what's happening with
with Citizens United but there's another
half to this and that is on the other
side we may not have the money but we
have our voices and if we get out there
and get organized and use our voices
I truly believe in grassroots I believe
in what we can do by linking up together
I believe in the power of what we can do
to build a country together one that
works not just for the top 1% or even
the top 10% but a country that works for
all of us
that's what it's got to be about our
country's on the line our democracies on
the line our futures on the line we've
got to use our time I really appreciate
it and you know think about the money
okay
you